in 1958 Japan Was preparing to host the
Olympic Games and was Keen to show the
world that it had evolved significantly
since the end of the second world war so
the Japanese government solidified plans
for their first ever high-speed Railway
line unlike other train systems which
often share tracks with slower a local
train shinkansen would operate on its
own dedicated routes moreover these
tracks were engineered with banked turns
allowing the train to maintain its
blistering speed to enhance the
smoothness of the ride the tracks
imployed continuous welded rail which
meant less friction which meant higher
speeds which meant less maintenance the
fastest steam trade in Japan at the time
topped out at 60 MPH with the fastest
trade in Japan now cruising at a speedy
200 mph today the average delay for a
Shinken train is less than 1 minute and
every single day about a quarter of a
million people ride the shinkansen in
Japan also after 50 years of continuous
operation and over 10 billion passengers
the shinkansen has never had a single
fatal accident officially making it the
world's safest train system